when you talk about the groomers  this stuff is real this stuff is  happening it's happening in  classrooms all over the country it's  real for a lot of families it's not  something that's happening to a small  fringe group of people that  are dealing with a child that has gender  dysphoria  that's not how it's happening it's  happening with you send your kids into a  school  and there's you know a drag queen doing  storytelling and talking about topics  that shouldn't be discussed and there  was no parental consent and you didn't  sign a form it's happening all the time  it's happening in school curriculums  across the country where they are now  forcing kids to  to absorb to swallow this heavily  politicized cultural content all the  time and normalizing things that parents  haven't deemed appropriate for their  four and five-year-old